Reading and math scores have long been
the primary measure of American
schooling. But how much do rising test
scores actually tell us about schools? A
lot less than we'd like!
In spring 2018, for instance, researchers
noted teacher impacts on test scores are
almost entirely uncorrelated with
teacher impacts on student classroom
behavior, attendance, truancy, and grades.
Why might that be?
Well, when test scores go up, it can mean
that students are learning more, but it
can also mean that schools are spending
a lot of time on test preparation,
shifting attention from other subjects
to reading and math, or gaming the
statistics. If a pediatrician started
seeing an impressive number of patients
because she stopped doing thorough
examinations, we probably would not
celebrate her performance. That's because
it matters how she improves her stats. In
the same way, it matters how schools
raise their test scores. Higher scores
may mean that schools are getting better,
or that they're just pretending to do so.
How much do you think test scores matter?
Let us know in your comments. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.